n'imaginez pas il ya encore quelques
mois que l'ukraine et la moldavie
pourrait être candidate à l'union
européenne et surtout aussi rapidement
puisque ça s'est fait en moins en moins
de quatre mois et ça c'est inédit dans
l'histoire de l'élargissement de l'union
européenne alors il a quand même fallu
lever quelques réticences à auprès de
certains états membres de l'union
européenne notamment le danemark et les
pays bas qui s'inquiétait de cette
perspective d'intégrer un pays comme
l'ukraine 1 qui compte quand même 44
millions d'habitants le portugal 1
également avait émis des réserves avant
de rejoindre la vie des grands pays
européens et de rejoindre la vie d'une
opinion plutôt favorable à l'or il faut
dire aussi que parmi les pays européens
il y en a qui ont poussé très fort pour
que cette candidature soit accordé à
l'ukraine et à la moldavie on pense bien
sûr à la pologne et à la lituanie mais
attention à on le sait c'est un
processus qui peut être très long ce
processus d'adhésion à d'ailleurs les
pays des balkans occidentaux peuvent en
témoigner eux qui frappent à la porte de
l'union européenne depuis très longtemps
pour certains on a l'exemple par exemple
de la macédoine du nord qui à ce statut
officiel de candidat à l'union
européenne depuis 17 ans